but yeah that went super well i mean i
think he's a nice guy he he i like how
he answers the with the perfect amount
of time his answers aren't too long they
aren't too short one of the problems i
have with interviewing academics is just
like they don't [ __ ] know where to
stop they don't [ __ ] know yeah it's
like a 10 minute presentation and you're
like well
now i have to kind of go back and say
like at the beginning of your
presentation you said this and i know
it's like eight minutes ago but let's
talk about that right it's really kind
of annoying actually um
okay give me a second i'll just record a
quick presentation
hello plastic pills and listeners uh a
lot of you have been looking down south
i'm sure and thinking what the hell is
going on there uh and well most of them
are probably our down south sorry to cut
you off there buddy that's true we
should keep this in
yes well for those of you who aren't in
uh snowy canada uh we actually have a
very special guest for you today uh this
is greg sergeant he is a washington post
opinion columnist who writes the plumb
line and he discourses a lot on the
subject of post-liberalism or national
conservatism and liberal egalitarianism
so thanks a lot for being on the show
greg great to have you
great thank you and and i guess he never
actually said thank you but i'm sure
that will that will suffice we recorded
this afterwards uh but anyway because we
wanted to use every single second
[Music]
so greg a lot of your writing is focused
on the emergence of these post-liberal
or national conservative movements and i
stress the term movement because one of
the things that we talk about a lot on
the show is the kind of theoretical
foundations um of this kind of politics
but we never really get into you know
the jd vances the tucker carlson's uh
you know the margie taylor greens of the
world so can you tell us a little bit
about what this new movement looks like
uh and what kind of political sport is
gaining in the united states and maybe
elsewhere
well the new right is really in some
respects a rebellion against the
republican party isn't it
one of the crucial things to me about
the new right is that they they
explicitly
say that the republican party has failed
to
aggressively deploy the state to fight
the culture wars
uh culture wars is of course a phrase
that i think is a euphemism but
it is awfully useful so as a shorthand
so i'm going to kind of stick to it if
that's okay with you guys
100
you know
what we're seeing with people like ron
desantis right now is a concerted effort
to show
what
it looks like when state power is
deployed in service of uh fighting
cultural enemies and bringing cultural
enemies to heal
so
i talked to a number of these new right
thinkers and they've elaborated fairly
you know sophisticated versions of this
uh if if that's the right word by
contrast what you've gotten people like
ron desantis and and
marjorie taylor green and
and even increasingly mainstream
republicans really is kind of a a moment
by moment almost like a fox news
friendly
effort to pick and choose the cultural
enemy of the moment and kind of use the
state in whatever haphazard way they can
to go after them
i thought it was really telling the
other day when jd vance essentially said
what we really need is a debatification
of the administrative state we need to
we need a purging of the administrative
state i take that as a very clear signal
that the next republican president
particularly if it's someone like
desantis as he's you know could very
well be
will deploy the administrative state
aggressively against cultural enemies
and i think
on some level
many republicans
for all their other faults genuinely are
uncomfortable with
so i was i was curious you know i was
looking at some of your tweets and some
of your writings um and i think one of
the observations you sort of make about
the new right is it seems like they're
paying more lip service to i guess
progressively economic policies or at
least like
but i i i detected some skepticism in
that it doesn't seem like they actually
concretely like they'll pay lip service
it seems like but maybe not actually
like endure specific like broad measures
like i don't know it varies i think uh
by like whatever post-liberal or like
you know integralist the different one
the the variety of these new right
figures but i guess what's your sense of
the of the extent to which they actually
are interested in concretely
economically progressive agendas and how
much of it is just really about culture
uh cultural change
so so i think we should give them some
credit on this and i've actually caught
some flack on this front but i think
there's like a legitimate
effort on the part of many new right
people including some in congress like i
guess marco rubio is in this vein
um although he's a bit of a complicated
figure but
anyway
i think we we should actually
acknowledge that they have a vision of
markets and distributive outcomes as
being in some sense created by
government socially created and and
that's really that really is a genuine
break i think
from what you might call everyday
libertarianism which is like the kind of
crude
worldview that republicans often use to
justify plutocracy right
um
and so
you know another thing we should get
credit them for is that they genuinely
do not think gdp is a measure of
national health i think that's really
true
now where it starts to break down at
least for me is what they do think can
be used
what they do what they do hold up is
goals in terms of
uh you know reconfiguring markets to
achieve social outcomes again giving
them a little credit right they do agree
with progressives that you can
reconfigure markets and you can change
market rules and you can use politics
and government to achieve other social
outcomes
but for me this is where the separation
starts they seem to really focus it on
things like the traditional family like
in consent using the state to
incentivize the traditional family they
have a vision there of that as a human
good and something that's essential to
human flourishing but like i asked in
one of my pieces
you know if we're going to use the state
if we're going to reconfigure markets to
achieve outcomes
that promote human flourishing why not
other bases for human flourishing that
are also fundamental like
universal health care or much more in
the way of education and
i've actually struggled with this and
i'd love to hear from you guys on it
what
what i tend to think is going on with
them is on some level they still have a
hierarchical view on some level they
don't take
moral equality seriously and that to me
is where the separation might lie
yeah and i would make the argument that
that's always been emblematic of the
political right generally and even the
libertarian right and there is a
libertarian left so we'll put that aside
uh yeah for those of you who are on it
you know i'm not knocking you in the
united states so for instance uh in the
mid 2010s you saw the emergence of what
are sometimes called bordertarians right
uh people who would argue that yeah we
want domestic free markets but that
doesn't mean that we should have a free
market in labor and we should have a
strong state that won't force the border
and you see a reflection of this
hierarchical world view there that we
should have free markets but only some
people should be able to benefit from
the freedom that that allows not
everyone because there are some people
who are ethnically uh or even racially
superior to others you know i'm thinking
somebody like stefan mullen you for
example right but you're on the kind of
post liberal point uh i think that what
you're saying is absolutely true right
that uh what they're trying to do is use
the state
not to corrode traditional and other
forms of hierarchies but to establish
the right kind of hierarchical
organization the one that they think the
market is incapable of actually
creating of its own merits and i think
that's where they really differ from
leftists wouldn't you say i i've been a
big fan of your points on that front
your continued insistence on saying look
you know they're still you know they're
still just searching it
i mean you you know how to articulate
this better than i do you have a much
obviously a much deeper theoretical
grounding but it does seem like on some
level
what they just want to do is is
create new hierarchies
um maybe they don't see them as in the
same way you know as as
you know your advertis your everyday
libertarian plutocrat does
but you know they certainly don't think
that state power should be used to
dismantle
the formation of hierarchies that
results from the private sector maybe
that's the way to think about it
i mean they would dispute that by the
way i think that's worth pointing out
like if you if you argue with someone
like nate
what's his name nate hochman who sort of
become a spokesperson the young kind of
he's like he's like a really amazingly
precocious guy and he's very smart i
don't know he actually collaborated uh
other than if he liked my work on
post-modern conservatism and we did it
back and forth on that so i'd love to
see that
anyway like he would he would dispute
that right i i believe on one of the
know your enemy podcasts um he he was a
guest
and i think he seemed open to some sort
of exchange of
a policy where you would do away with
endowments for certain types of
four-year
degrees and channel some of that into
vocational school which by the way is
another way of maintaining a certain
type of hierarchy i think but that's you
know something we could talk about but
he seemed open to the idea of um pairing
that with some kind of minimum wage hike
what i think maybe the most fundamental
thing is
that there isn't really a discernable
vision of distributive justice
at the core of what they do and and i
think they would probably admit that
right because
conservatives tend
as a rule to be skeptical of
distributive justice schemes don't they
i mean that's something i'm sure you
guys both know better than i do
no for sure i mean i think they are uh
skeptical because i think just
emphasizing distribution by itself in
fact i think some of the critics from
both the left and right in like the
political theory world is that like just
emphasizing um distributive justice like
doesn't really tell you that much about
like the community so from a left it
like doesn't tell you that much about
like solidarity the civic virtues in the
society and i think for the right and
for the for the new right it's like
distributive justice tells you nothing
about the kind of values that that
society is going to have or at least
like you know family values commitments
to like self-discipline right which are
all kind of like so i think that makes a
lot of sense that that they're not going
to just be purely interested
um
in distributive justice i was curious
about also you know you write about how
the new write also has a tendency and
fixation on kind of like narratives of
catastrophe right so a lot of a lot of
their concern with the way that
and their newfound critiques of
capitalism is the way it's eroding these
kinds of traditional values and there's
this like narrative of catastrophe and
maybe you could talk a little bit about
that and also i'm curious whether you
think there's an analogous kind of
narrative of catastrophe on the left or
if there's something else if you have
thoughts about that
yeah i mean what i've been calling it is
and i don't think i came up with this uh
is cultural catastrophism
which i think is really sort of a very
dangerous tendency
um
you know
when when you i thought a really telling
thing the other day was jd vance
discussing his um his his uh his um
justification for supporting trump right
so the way he talks about it is okay
you guys just for the benefit of your
viewers jd vance is running for senate
in ohio he's running in a republican
primary
he's kind of the you know trumpest pop
quote-unquote populist nationalist
candidate author of hillbilly elegy for
those who don't know yes right right
right and so but in 2016 he was a
different person and he criticized trump
pretty aggressively
i think he described trump or at least
his type of politics as cultural heroine
uh for the white working class right
which you know is a language that people
like
you and you and me can can relate to and
then all of a sudden he becomes a
trumpist and there's been a lot of talk
about how he's you know been an
opportunist but i i think that we should
take it a little more seriously if you
look closely at the arguments he's made
what he says is well okay i i didn't
understand that trump was going to open
all of our eyes
to uh the corrupt rot at the core of
elite liberal institutions
and and you know so he treats trump as
kind of like this providential figure
who's caused the scales to fall from his
eyes you know and and kind of created
almost a divine revelation of what's
really been around him the kind of evil
rot that's all around him and and so
once you go down that road right pretty
much anything is justified in response
to
this type of cultural emergency that
that he suddenly senses in every
institution and around every corner in
every classroom and so
you know um
that's what i'm talking about really
it's really just a short leap from there
to just saying oh well our you know our
elections are corrupt um
right the deep state is corrupt and so
when the deep state says that russia's
trying to overturn our election it's
just baloney it's just
elite corruption at work
um
when you know when people
demand that disinform an end to
disinformation about our elections
that's more of the same and so there's
no actual kind of
uh set of sort of
i don't know guard rails
at any point once you've sort of
accepted that
the entire
superstructure of everything is rotten
to its core
and that's the that's what i mean by the
kind of cultural catastrophism and
they're pretty open about it which is
kind of odd no absolutely i mean one of
the other things that you've seen
on the political right ever since
trump's kind of rise to power is that
they've all become kind of implicit
hegelians right hegel had this argument
that sometimes an individual might seem
deeply deficient in some respects but
nonetheless the cunning of reason was
this phrase might use them for ends that
then the sauce wouldn't have chosen
and you see people make these kind of
claims about trump all the time right
that yeah he's boorish yeah he might
have deep personal flaws
but nevertheless providence has selected
him as a kind of individual who's going
to engage in this world historical
overcoming of you know the decadence
decay of liberalism
and usually associated with this kind of
future minded triumphalism is this deep
sense that you know the country is
decayed that this is our last chance uh
that everything's falling apart right
and didn't actually quickly didn't uh
didn't steve bannon say that about trump
uh actually greg i'm curious if you ever
talked to benjamin title bomb uh do you
know who that is he wrote this book the
war for eternity
no i don't no
oh it's it's so good like he he's this
ethnographer from the university of
colorado boulder who ended up scoring
like 20 hours from hassling steve bannon
of just like interviews with him and
just hung around with him for like hours
and he wrote this amazing book about
like the theoretical underpinnings
of bannon uh and like traditionalism and
like that whole like really far right
wing and like dugan you know like which
is in the news now
more from like russia and stuff so yeah
uh you just matt what you were saying
reminded me of title bomb telling us
about how bannon i think he says in that
book thought that trump is the vehicle
of this like broader cultural this like
this historical necessity of like you
know uh some sort of new right emerging
right and i think so you see this with
jd vance saying you know strip the
administrative state of all liberals and
turn it loose on on you know
corporations
and and you know when when steve bannon
i don't know if you listen to his
podcast but i'd recommend if you can
stomach it you know
listen listen a little bit because i've
had older story
yeah it's it's pretty bad it's really
it's it's it's really raw right-wing
insurgency stuff it's
yeah it's it's it takes it as a given
that
that future election outcomes that are
that where where they lose will be
subject to to nullification by any means
necessary i think
they really do take it as a given it's
just stated as essentially as fact
no absolutely and i think that one of
the things that's deeply disturbing of
course about all these movements uh is
many of us predicted that they might
have authoritarian
strands as soon as trump was elected um
but none of us quite expected that it
would be so spectacularly displayed as
you saw in january 2021 right where
there was an insurrection and it was
backed by major figures in the
administration and while there was a
little bit of initial pushback from the
gop everyone kind of got on board with
it including vance and others so can you
tell us a little bit about why you think
that they are entitled
to kind of adopt this approach towards
democratic procedures what is it about
elections that make them unfair if their
preferred candidate doesn't win because
that would seem to just be the operative
assumption of democracy right you know
think about this madisonian ethos that
one of the reasons why everyone would be
content with democracy is if your guy
didn't win today well they'll always be
tomorrow right
yeah i mean i i think something very
complicated is going on with the
republicans and unfortunately the way
it's discussed in the mainstream press
tends to kind of slather it in euphemism
and stuff
if you think about it says an example of
that and this will get around to
where i think you want me to go
um over and over we hear oh republican
candidates are running on the big lie
right you know they're loyal to trump
and and that just completely misstates
the real story of what's happening right
so
what you're hearing from many republican
candidates across the country yes they
they do have to pledge fealty to the big
lie but what's actually happening is
they're running on an implicit vow to be
willing to use whatever procedural power
they can and perhaps more
to
maximally contest future election losses
right and so
i think to answer your question it's not
that they sort of say oh well we're
justified in doing this
it's sort of in a more shadowy place
right they don't sort of say openly
all right well we will overturn the next
election loss they don't say it that way
they usually use kind of coded language
that keeps it
very nebulous and sort of deliberately
so
so that they can kind of appeal to swing
voters as well without you know without
but so they can avoid alienating those
voters take david perdue and georgia
right this is a really really really
good example of this he is trump's
candidate in the republican
gubernatorial primary against incumbent
republic uh incumbent republican
governor brian kemp now brian kemps is
being challenged for the explicit reason
that he refused to steal the election
for trump in 2020. and david perdue
doesn't say
our elections don't count i will steal
the next election he doesn't say it that
way what he says is brian kemp let you
down he didn't fight
right
um and then when he's asked directly
would you have certified
uh
trump
joe biden's electors in 2020 he says no
right because there was vote fraud and
so it just becomes this shadowy set of
claims where what they're really saying
is
you know
i will maximally use whatever procedural
tools are available at my disposal
and use lies about voter fraud to
justify it in a way that these other
squish republicans didn't
and and so
there's not actually any kind of real
justification other than the sort of
invented
phantasm of fraud but
if you analyze it closely it's a clear
statement of intent and it's almost
never remarked on in the press which is
you know a real problem i think yeah and
i think that's one of the things that us
liberals really find difficult when it
comes to dialoguing or critiquing people
who hold these views because they are
slippery and what you can sometimes find
is if you make a point that they're
unable to argue against empirically
they'll just find a way to use that as
further vindication for their viewpoints
right i mean i found this about january
6. uh people would start off by saying
you know it didn't happen or it wasn't
as bad as they said and then if it was
as bad as people claimed then they'd say
well antifa was there right and they're
the ones who really riled up so even
though they're seeding at one point
they're using that as a kind of further
circular way of indicating their
viewpoint uh and you know this is all
very strange and people call that a lot
of different things including me um but
you know i'm wondering can you tell us a
little bit about where the roots of this
come from uh because i think that's what
a lot of us are
really wondering uh looking from you
know the outside in and people have
diagnosed different kind of points where
trumpism got its seeds uh or
post-liberalism or national
conservatives and whatever you want to
call it some people will say well
there's the bush administration you know
there's this famous argument that we
create our own reality now
uh that you know various people you know
in the war on terror used to kind of
espouse some people say newt gingrich
other people say reagan where do you
think it began uh and why did it evolve
the way it did
the gingrich moment strikes me is really
important because that's when politics
became a national total war maybe in a
bit of a different way
you know
even
liberals have a bit of a nostalgized
you know
a soft and soft and fuzzy view of the
reagan years i think i mean i i'm a
millennial right so you know i i buy
into 80s nostalgia like anyone else yeah
yeah right right i mean they're like
yeah exactly i mean it's just it's a
component of 80s nostalgia you know
having lived through the 80s in in new
york city and going to school in the
bronx um
i don't i don't know why people
nostalgize it but anyway um
uh anyways what i was going to say is
that yes i think gingrich is um a very
key turning point he he teaches
republicans that everything is max is
total war
that that the democratic enemy must be
portrayed in the absolute most lurid and
menacing and hyperbolic and
insane way possible and that it should
be a concerted strategy
and and so forth
but i also think that a lot of this is
rooted in
the
kind of escalation of
manipulation of
the rules and procedures of democracy
that really started to pick up steam
after obama
right
people kind of forget this but the 2010
elections in which republicans won the
house they also won you know
dozens of state legislatures across the
country
and it's kind of at that moment where
you start to see
a really escalated effort to gerrymander
and to suppress votes and to do that
sort of thing
um that
that i think leads down to the present
moment in the kind of following way
right
at that point republicans were openly
terrified of demographic change right
they were essentially saying okay the
obama presidency has shown us that we
are on the losing end of this
demographic battle
and you know we've really got to step up
the the procedural warfare and of course
they did that right they did it very
successfully and democrats got caught
napping and by the way we're still
dealing with the fallout of that right
now in in some terrible ways
but you know anyway what happened was
little by little you know
the use of things like voter fraud
became more and more entrenched as an
excuse to fight procedural warfare in
maximal ways
and i actually talked to a republican
pollster about this who thought his
party was going crazy on it and he
essentially told me look when i pull um
it's in my book by the way
he said when when when i pull republican
voters on this stuff what i find is they
are starting to think that
that voter suppression is
already a rearguard response to a
massive cheating scheme that's being
leveled against them in which democrats
use government policies to give money to
undeserving people to buy their votes
and so
you know republican voters think oh well
if they're going to fight that way we're
going to fight our way and so you can
see that coming right down to the
present
trump comes in and he makes the whole
voter fraud argument much more explicit
he starts to say straight out he singles
out urban centers as the centers for
fraud
in a much more visceral and open way
and there you have a pretty straight up
racial argument right as opposed to
before it was just okay voter fraud you
know demographic change he's saying you
know the cities are stealing the
elections from you out there and
non-cosmopolitan america
and then that really leads down to kind
of this
cultural catastrophism that i'm talking
about and you know right now or
they're literally it's it's crossed from
using voter fraud
to justify voter suppression
to now using
the lie of a stolen election
to justify voter suppression in the name
of election integrity and so you can
just kind of see it kind of torquing up
little by little kind of out of those
moments
i'm curiou do you have a sense for kind
of like how much these new right
movements are
like influenced by these new right
intellectuals right because we have the
jd the movements but then we've got like
the vermuels which i think maybe you've
written or at least tweeted about common
good constitutionalism and probably like
looked at some of matt's work on on on
his mat always reviewing the
conservative books uh and then
uh you know the the patrick dineens and
stuff
like
so do you do you think that they're
actually like reading like the the
actual like political actors like like
jd vance and them are familiar with
their work or is it just kind of like
two independently developing
fields of the right wing that are just
like uh developing kind of independently
of each other because they both have a
broad sense or is there actual like
connection to invoke our colleague uh do
ideas matter you know
yeah no i think i think like to take
these guys seriously again i i think so
yeah i i think jd vance reads the
journals he pays close attention to
what claremont institute is doing and so
forth i mean
i forget what the name of gladden
pappins journal is called it's either
american purpose or american affairs one
of those um
it's a it's sort of really a new right
um gladden papin you guys know he's
caught sort of in the integralist camp
and he's a serious guy in his own way i
mean i there's a new i think there's a
rutledge handbook of post-liberalism out
there that was edited by stephen holmes
and some others and it's it's a it's an
interesting book and glenn happen has a
chapter making the case from his side so
this is a serious guy
his journal i think is read by people
like marco rubio and josh hawley i mean
i'm pretty convinced that there's that
they take this
intellectual movement extremely
seriously i just
to me
i again what where it breaks down for me
is is in in in the in some of the
failings you were talking about earlier
they just don't
they don't seem to have a real
economic vision
that is
that takes
distributive justice or moral equality
seriously and and that that's where i
think you and i you guys and and people
like me really part ways from them but i
do think they're serious about it it's
an interesting question maybe you guys
have thoughts on this if you think about
the idea of
going after
college endowments four-year college
stuff to to fund vocational school what
i and matt this is like your
this is your topic right
dignified self-authorship when i look at
that
right i see hierarchy being maintained
because they're not taking the idea
seriously from of
that moral equality should lead us to
say you get the resources to realize
yourself
right they just sort of say okay well
you know four-year colleges are
indoctrinating people
vocational work
is is a good option it'll keep it'll
create communities that we think are
stable that's not taking moral liberal
moral equality seriously is it
no i don't think so uh so just to say
something about this and then um so just
very briefly i think
people sometimes ponder why it is that
the right simultaneously has this real
attraction uh to its own intellectuals
while advocating uh for
anti-intellectual kinds of rhetoric
elsewhere right you think about trump's
comment about i love the undereducated
right you know they're my people that
kind of thing this has really deep roots
going back to even someone like edmund
burke uh but you know the point of it
was never really made that explicit uh
until you get to somebody like roger
scrutin in his book the menial
conservatism where he overtly says that
there is something admirable from a
conservative standpoint about what he
called and i quote unthinking people
right uh those who accept the burdens
that life bears opposes upon them
without seeking to lodge blame uh where
they have little chance of recourse and
i think you see this in this kind of
emphasis on vocational schools there's
this idea that there's nothing wrong
with you getting an education as long as
it's an education that leads to you
being broadly speaking uncritical of the
political and traditional institutions
that you inhabit um
and so to the extent that there is a
movement on things like access to
post-secondary education it's probably
going to take this form you're never
going to see conservatives sitting there
being like we should fund all kinds of
people who are going to be coming out of
university with all kinds of different
opinions about how things should be
shored like others should be um changed
it's not what they're really aspiring to
and to the extent that they're looking
to kind of train an intellectual cadre
it's going to be an intellectual cadre
that more or less replicates or
parrots the kind of viewpoints that they
think are acceptable but i mean this is
what i kind of wanted to get this
actually gets at my final question for
you uh which is what do you think that
we can do as liberals or leftists uh to
confront these movements because they've
been very appealing uh they definitely
have a kind of intellectual backbone to
them uh which sometimes we don't
appreciate uh and while we kind of got a
bit of a course uh in 2020 with biden's
election a lot of us are worried that is
just that it's a reprieve or of course
and that something worse is going to be
coming down the line so what can we do
well you know i'm not sure this is a
great answer it might be kind of
too overly theoretical but my sort of
sense is that
what liberalism can do is kind of return
to the tradition of egalitarian
liberalism as a response to
right wing populism
it seems to me that if we return if we
take seriously the idea
that moral equality requires an
investment of societal social and
economic resources and the ability of
people to realize themselves then we
kind of tackle
some of the very liabilities about
liberalism that right-wing populism is
exploiting you know for instance the
kind of
efforts to entrench meritocracy that
they constantly and i think
somewhat legitimately attack right
um
now i think we're in a very bad moment
for the following reason we had a shot
here at something that would move in
that direction fairly dramatically in
biden's buildback better agenda it would
have invested you know
much more money in education health care
and and so forth and you know
that dying
um
is really really a problem for for for
liberals i think because that was kind
of
right i mean that was our out that this
is our crack at rehabilitating
liberalism along the lines that i think
we all agree it should be and
and
you know i don't want to be pollyanish
about this like there's sort of a
pollyannish thing where you're thinking
about this which says something along
the lines of you know well right-wing
populists are just exploiting the fact
that liberals haven't
that are liberals have maintained the
meritocracy i think that's
you know it
put it this way i don't really believe
that's why trump won or why there's a
populist surge but i do think that
as a matter of theoretical argument
that's what our best rebuttal to
right-wing populism is
uh egalitarian liberalism
yeah that makes that makes sense to me
i'm definitely persuaded and actually
going from that point i mean in in the
last couple minutes here
um i think i read you sort of expressing
some skepticism about like a lot of the
internal and obviously external
critiques of the way that liberalism in
america and like you know the way you
you guys use liberal to mean left of
center um
in america is now dominated by what
people call wokeness or whatever right
and like that's the big boogie man
but i guess you know but i guess i'm
curious like because it seems like
you're a little skeptical of this idea
that in order for the left to be
successful you know like wokeness needs
to be eliminated i mean maybe i
misinterpreted what i thought i saw you
uh writing about so i i think i'd take a
middle ground there and i i don't mean
to be weasely you know
but i actually think that what we should
be trying to do is separating the good
from the bad and wokeness
right i mean you know
large swaths of what we call identity
politics are perfectly in keeping with
uh
liberal commitments and i think we just
have to be clearer on what types of
wokeness violate those commitments and
what don't we have to also say that a
lot of them don't right because
otherwise we see the opportunity to say
things like well you know martin luther
king was critical of the racist
superstructure of society and so we
can't give that away we can't sort of
say oh the only thing that we're allowed
to say is is that colorblind you know is
that colorblind equality is the goal
um and so
that's why i really liked mallory and
mcmarro's moment she's a michigan for
your viewers mallory mcmorrow is the
michigan
state senator who had a viral moment
when she
tore into the republican opposition for
depicting her as a groomer and what she
did was she kind of returned to first
principles uh in the wokeness to be
right she essentially said you're damn
i'm a white christian suburban mom i
absolutely am for equality
um and that's because i recognize uh you
know the the the humanity of of the of
the
non-white and non-christian
uh students in in um in
my my children's school and what i keep
wondering is what the people who are
making the anti-woke argument think of
that right where does that fit into
their their schema right i mean this is
someone who
went in a very big and loud way
raised the salience of of all these
questions about trans and gay rights and
and
and and racial equality is that
something we don't want i mean
i think we want we want democrats to
talk like that don't we and and so i
would ask the people who are saying well
we have to eliminate wokeness does that
mean
democrats shouldn't speak from deep
conviction about racial um equality and
and the need to protect
gay rights and trans rights and so forth
i don't see it i mean there's got to be
a way
that we can manage this kind of you know
admittedly tricky
minefield of ideas we we say what we
believe
we say when things when wokeness
and certain curricula violate
uh those beliefs
and and we say look we understand that
you're concerned about all the talk
you're hearing about gay and trans
rights and and you're absolutely right
to be concerned about it you know these
are your children we're talking about
but you know here's why we believe this
stuff
we can't we say that it's got it's got
to be doable i guess maybe really really
last question if i if we have time um
you know as you you're you observe
american political culture we've been
talking about kind of how bad things are
getting right now how polarized it is
and sometimes people make these high
fluent claims were going to lead to a
civil war which i think probably all
three of us are a little bit skeptical
about but i'm curious what is your
realistic worst case scenario like what
is a worst case scenario that you think
is actually like reasonably imaginable
oh i don't know i think you could see
i'm not going to say this is likely at
all right i think it probably is very
unlikely like a lot of things would have
to happen but i think you could easily
see
a stolen election in 2024
especially if republicans win some of
these governorships in swing states
this is a fact that's not widely
understood i think but
all it takes to flip an election is if
an election comes down to one swing
state
and a republican governor certifies a
fake set of electors in defiance of the
popular vote and a republican-controlled
house of representatives which we are
likely to have in 2024
counts those votes even if the democrats
in the senate oppose that they would
pretty much stand you need the courts to
do certain things but i could see that i
could see street violence accompanying
it in a stepped-up way
you know i i also again i want to stress
that i think those things are unlikely
but
i think we should take them seriously as
possibilities all right chilling
to end on
yeah but
but but good to good to be realistic all
right
well thanks so much greg i mean it's
been really good talking to you yeah
really appreciate your time yeah thanks
a lot greg uh it's great to finally talk
to you uh not quite one-on-one but as
close to one-on-one as we get these days
yeah was that did you think do you think
musk musk good for twitter or bad
i i think you know that's too big a
question maybe i think the jury's out on
that um
you know i i think there's a real
likelihood that he will
turn a blind eye to very virulent forms
of right-wing disinformation and violent
speech
yeah i worry about that too i think so
all right thanks so much guys thanks so
much
[Music]
you